Donald Trump goes international he
Hobnobs at the g7 and he hangs out with
kim jeong-hoon we have all the latest
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show many things to discuss here today
the Tony Awards also happened we also
have to talk about this insane editorial
from The Washington Post from a
professor of Gender Studies shocker ok
but first I want to explain that we have
a couple of things coming up so tomorrow
June 12th 7 p.m. Eastern for your
viewing pleasure not for our doing
pleasure we are doing a special live
stream in honor of Father's Day daily
where God king Jeremy boring hosts a
roundtable discussion with me Andrew
Clavin and Michael Mills plus we have
special guests I found so Rachel and
Nick Searcy we're gonna discuss the role
of fathers in our society so a lot of
fathers plus michael moles will be live
streaming on facebook and youtube and if
you're a daily water subscriber go to
daily wire.com to submit live questions
to us which will be moderated by Alicia
Kraus again that is tomorrow Tuesday
June 12th 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
and do not miss it plus our next episode
of the conversation is almost here so on
Tuesday June 19th at 5:30 p.m. 2:30 p.m.
Pacific all of your questions will be
answered by me wait I'm doing one of
these again ok with our host Alicia
cross our live Q&A will be available on
YouTube and Facebook for everybody to
watch but only derrial it daily where
subscribers can ask me questions in real
time to submit those questions log into
daily wire.com head over to the
conversation page to watch the live
stream type your question into the daily
wire chat box to have it read and
answered on air again you have to
subscribe to ask me those live questions
on Tuesday June 19th at 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific and join the
conversation it's fun when you find out
about things right is you're reading
about them but it's just great ok before
we even get to his news it was a long
weekend folks it really was a long
weekend of my kids woke me up at 3:45 in
the morning on Saturday morning I'll
explain it in the things I hate but yes
any of that first I'm gonna say thanks
to our sponsors over a man crate so man
crates ok let's get serious because man
crates okay it's time Father's Day is
coming it's coming and you're an idiot
so you didn't get your dad anything
right I know I know you're stupid so go
over to man crates right now and get
your dad something awesome so this
Father's Day give your dad the gift use
guarantee to love with man crates
hand-picked packaged gifts for every
type of dad they've got the knife making
kit for the hands-on serial killer dad
or the whiskey appreciation crate
for fathers who like the finer things
and are also alcoholics they have plenty
of kits for anyone like seriously yet
plenty of dads out there and they have I
have like three of these kits already
and they're just awesome as I've said
before I've got the poker kit and then I
believe I just got what was it I got a
grilling kit as well because I need to
learn two grills that I'm
self-sufficient at home apparently I'm
not according to my wife but this is why
you need a man crate and with the man
crates you're giving your dad more than
just the gift you're giving him a gift
experience unlike any other Plus every
man Craig comes with a 100% satisfaction
guarantee the coolest thing is they come
in actual crate hence the name man
crates and then you pry it open with a
crowbar get your special Father's Day
discount today at man crates calm slash
Ben it's a limited time offer
only for Father's Day go today don't
leave your dad bereft it is man crates
calm slash Ben and use that slash pen
for the special deal again man crates
calm slash Ben to let them know that we
sent you alright so finally onto the
news and you would think that the news
would be less ridiculous than that
opener you would be wrong my friends
President Trump is headed over to
Singapore for his meeting with Kim
jong-un the human time bomb a man who
looks as though he was built in the
model of fat man and little boy so he
apparently is meeting with President
Trump one on one which is just the way
you want this meeting to start what you
really want in a meeting between
President Trump and Kim jong-un a
dictator of a country and a guy who is
most famous for not reading his morning
briefings isn't one-on-one meeting hey
listen I think the president Trump is
good at a great many things I do not
think that he is a great negotiator
one-on-one with people armed with
nuclear weapons just a hunch I'm not
sure that this is the way you want this
me and go now maybe president from
surprises he'll maybe what's actually
happening here is that Kim jong-un the
dictator of North Korea blew up his
nuclear mountain maybe he destroyed his
nuclear mountain right there's been talk
about this he has a nuclear mountain
that was hollowed out so that he could
actually do bomb tests in there and he
blew the thing up apparently so it's
possible that he's now coming to the
west and saying guys I'm ready to disarm
because he disarmed himself by blowing
up his nuclear mountain and Trump is
just the beneficiary that we're gonna
find out but President Trump is meeting
with him and it's not clear what the
agenda is going to look like so first of
all I love this vice president Pence was
asked about president Trump's
preparations for all of this and it's
pretty spectacular what he said at the
Faith and Freedom Coalition is quote now
comes the his
Dork summit between the presidents of
the United States and chairman Kim of
North Korea as president from said this
week he's approaches that he approaches
the summit with confidence the truth is
he's been preparing for this his whole
life when my kid honestly I just have to
ask was president Trump preparing for it
when President Trump was like posing for
the cover of Playboy
or was he more doing it when he was
banging around like the the clubs in the
1970s or was he mostly doing it when he
was on the set of The Celebrity
Apprentice like I'm fine with President
Trump handling these negotiations he
can't handle negotiations with a
nuclear-armed or semi nuclear-armed
country better worse than President
Barack Obama handled the negotiations
with the Iranians right there's no way
to do that so I'm not saying that this
goes horribly but vice president Pence
has a dramatic tendency I think to
overstate the the genius of the man for
whom he works even though he's really
elected by the American people and he
really works for us but his boss right
the presidents of the United States he's
very fond you may have noticed in any
case President Trump did a presser as he
was leaving the g7 this is the last
presser that he has done before he
headed over to the Singapore the
Singapore meeting I know that a lot of
people were really optimistic about this
thing I'm far less optimistic I don't
think that you ought to give a meet up
to a dictator of a country without
actually going in with some
preconditions like here's what you're
gonna give up Kim hasn't really given
anything up he gave up a few hostages I
guess that's something but I'm not sure
that you had to guarantee a meeting in
order to make that happen you probably
could have done that with a little bit
of cash or with some low-level
negotiations elevating a dictator who's
enslaving millions of people in a giant
gulag to the status of world leader
doesn't seem to me like a great move you
know I was angry when Barack Obama met
with the Iranians I was angry when
Barack Obama met with the Cubans you
remember he went over to Cuba which is
another gulag state and then he hung out
there and went to a baseball game and
everybody on the right was angry about
it they're fighting mad about it same
people on the right who were fighting
mad about that are not fighting me out
about President Trump meeting with Kim
jong-un with no preconditions and really
no agenda when I say there's no agenda
it's not really me who's just saying
this here's President Trump explaining
what the agenda is and what he how he
thinks this thing is going to go well
there's always everything it's really
you know this has probably rarely been
done it's unknown territory in the
truest sense but I really feel confident
I feel
that Kim jong-un wants to do something
great for his people and he has that
opportunity and he won't have that
opportunity again it's never gonna be
there again okay so now obviously
they're going in with a clear agenda and
I love that president from explains the
clear agenda he's asked what is the
objective of these meetings here is his
explanation I have a clear objective but
I have to say Ilyana that it's going to
be something that will always be spur of
the moment you don't know okay so which
is it is there a clear objective or is
it gonna be spur-of-the-moment I know
that that's how I go into all my
contract negotiations I say I have a
clear objective but I'm gonna go just
you know it's spur-of-the-moment just
gonna wing it bring a disco ball maybe
some sangria just have a good time I
mean if that's what I do so it's I don't
know what this is supposed to accomplish
again maybe I'm wrong maybe this
accomplishes everything maybe and we end
up with an indie nuclearized North Korea
I am skeptical at best because the fact
is the kim jeong-hoon is not going to
give up his nuclear weapons the reason
he's not gonna give up his nuclear
weapons is the minute that he does he's
now vulnerable to a Western coup attempt
that's the reason he's pursuing this
thing in the first place
I mean according to the Associated Press
President Trump plans to depart early
from his unprecedented summit with Kim
jong-il in the White House said on
Monday declaring the nuclear talks of
North Korea's have moved more quickly
than expected okay Trump had been
scheduled to fly back to Washington on
Wednesday morning after spending Tuesday
with the North Korean leader in
Singapore around the eve of the summit
he altered his schedule opting to return
about 8:00 p.m. on Tuesday after a full
day of meetings with Kim almost 15 hours
earlier than previously anticipated this
is probably smart move by the White
House because what you don't want is for
Trump to stick around and for Kim to go
out and say something publicly and then
Trump says something publicly and then
they get into a fistfight or something
the White House said in a statement the
discussions between the United States
and North Korea are ongoing and have
moved more quickly than expected it
wasn't immediately clear what specific
progress if any had been made in the
preliminary discussions between the u.s.
and North Korean officials in the run-up
to the Tuesday summit in fact only hours
before the White House announcement US
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo had
seemed to lower expectations for the
meeting which Trump had predicted could
potentially yield an on-the-spot deal to
end the Korean War and here's the
problem with President Trump generally
when it comes to negotiations President
Trump is a great marketer I mean it is
the thing he's best at he's amazing at
marketing well if you are very good at
marketing one of
things you tend to do is over promise
you tend to do this right every
commercial you have ever watched it is
the case of somebody over promising
right when you watch a commercial on TV
and they show you those nice juicy
burgers that look amazing what those
really are are those plastic mock-ups
that have been sprayed with water so
they'll call moist and juicy and if you
ate them you would literally choke and
die right because virtually every ad on
television is an oversell president
Trump does a lot of overselling he says
he has the biggest crowds ever he said
that his campaign movement was the
biggest ever
he says the dissociation is going to be
the biggest everything is the biggest
ever everything is unprecedented the
biggest ever well the problem is when
you oversell an international
negotiation people sort of expect that's
going to happen Pompeyo said on Monday
we're hopeful the summit will have set
the conditions for future successful
talks which is really him saying we
didn't really get much done here and
then President Trump said what was his
actual objective well he explained again
at the g7 what his actual objective was
he said he had a clear objective but
he's gonna be spur-of-the-moment which
is weird and then he said that the
minimum would be and this is really what
Trump thinks about the art of the deal
you know that his book the art of the
deal which was not written by President
Trump that's really not how he
negotiation how he negotiates president
Trump is very interpersonal
relationships he negotiates with people
I mean I know a lot of people who know
President Trump who knew him before he
was president president Trump is very
reliant on him forging ties with the
person with whom he is negotiating he
likes to have a good personal
relationship with the person with whom
he is talking and that's essentially
what he said about kim jeong-hoon
well I think the minimum would be
relationship you'd start at least a
dialogue because you know as a deal
person I've done very well with deals
what you want to do is start that now
I'd like to accomplish more than that
but at a minimum I do believe at least
we'll have met each other we will have
seen each other hopefully we will have
liked each other and we'll start that
process so the President of the United
States is very much focused on whether
he gets along with foreign leaders we'll
see that this comes up in a different
context when we get to the g7 because
his relationships with foreign leaders
of the g7 are not going it so swimmingly
but if he believes that he's gonna forge
some sort of personal tie with kim
jeong-hoon that i think is a mistake
again I do not think that negotiations
generally are based on personal ties
between leaders I don't think that it
was the Ronald Reagan had this wonderful
relationship with Mikhail Gorbachev and
that's why I got an end to the Cold War
it's really more like the Soviets
bankrupted themselves and they were
attempting really I mean you look at
their internal documents and this is
what they were saying they were
attempting to hold on to their Soviet
empire but they just hadn't didn't have
the money or the resources to do so this
was also true with regard to for example
South Africa which wanted to disarm the
reason they wanted to disarm is because
they wanted to be reintegrated into the
family of nations it wasn't the
leadership of South Africa had wonderful
relationships at the west and so they
decided to do a deal I've been part of
several major business deals myself a
good relationship is not harmful but if
there's no confluence of interest then a
personal relationship is not going to
mean very much I've gotten along with a
lot of people with whom I've tried to do
a deal and the deal just never comes
together I've done a lot of deals with
people who I don't particularly like but
there's a confluence of interest and so
that happens now president Trump's view
of a deal which is that you get in the
room you hash it out you make good we
make friends with people it means the
president Trump is very good in the room
but it also means that he could be
suckered and this is why I don't like
the idea of him being in a loan alone in
a room with Kim jong-un and adjust their
translators first of all you never know
what the translator for the for the
North Koreans is actually going to say
back to kim jeong-hoon i mean i assume
that trumps translator will know but
that's pretty much it and second of all
Trump alone in a room with people has
not ended well in terms of negotiations
the last time Trump was alone in a room
with somebody who's alone in a room with
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi and he
offered them a budget deal that broke
the bank and overruled his own
Republican Party the time before that he
was alone in the room with foreign
leaders he was in alone in the room with
the foreign ambassador from Russia and
he ended up saying to him the fire James
Comey over the Russian investigation so
I just think there's a situation right
foot with the possibility for problems
maybe nothing comes of it but if nothing
comes of it then what was the purpose of
any of this other than I guess a
photo-op that makes Kim jong-un looks
stronger in the world as a parallel
leader with the most powerful leader on
planet earth the entire media treating
that is a coup that Trump is meeting
with Kim Jong loon I just don't
understand that mentality it's a Cooper
Kim true that he gets to meet with the
President of the United States it'd be a
coup for you if you got to meet with the
presidents of the United States would
not be a coup for you if you got to meet
with Kim Jong hoon it would likely mean
you were about to be shot yes I have a
few more thoughts on this in just a
second first honestly thanks to our
sponsors / betterment so betterment is
the largest online financial adviser
designed to help customers build wealth
plan for retirement and achieve their
financial glow so I have a financial
advisor because I don't have time to sit
there and pretend I know what I'm doing
with day trading I don't have time to
sit there and vet invest
instead I have a financial advisor who
does all that stuff for me what
betterment you can have exactly those
same sorts of services except online and
betterment is great because there are no
hidden costs there no there they're low
fees no matter who you are or how much
money you invest you get everything all
of their services from one low
transparent management fee and as a
fiduciary they make recommendations in
their clients best interest they're not
incentivized to recommend particular
funds they don't have their own
investment products to sell so it's not
somebody selling you their own stuff in
an attempt to make Commission off of you
instead they're getting a management fee
and it's a low management feed manage
your stuff and ensure that you have a
good financial plan in place betterment
offers personalized advice and it's a
suite of tools to help you know whether
you're on track to hit your investment
goals or get the retirement you want and
when you need it their tools and
guidance can help you get on track as
well now investing always involves risk
but one of the ways that you can ensure
that that risk is minimized is by using
a financial adviser Ben Shapiro sure
listeners can get up to one year
management for free for more information
visit betterment comm slash Shapiro
that's betterment comm slash Shapiro
btter ent comm slash capiro go out and
check it out
betterment comm slash creating up to a
year management for free it's it's
something that everyone who is
responsible with finances but doesn't
have time or inclination to handle their
own finances should do okay so what's
the outcome going to be from all of this
well here's what you hope the outcome is
not well you hope the outcome is not as
demon clear ization of the Korean
Peninsula so there's been a lot of talk
about the President of the United States
going in and removing troops from the
mainland from from taking troops off of
the South Korean Peninsula and allowing
the North Koreans essentially free reign
over the peninsula with Chinese pressure
President Trump has pursued a rather
isolating foreign policy there are
certain allies he's grown close to like
Israel his Middle East policy I think
has been quite good because it's been
anti Iran but his his asian-pacific
policy has been really a shambles it's
been a shambles since he decided to
reject the trans-pacific partnership now
their trans-pacific partnership is
negotiated by President Obama had some
very serious flaws had some very serious
holes in it and those could have been
rectified by working to fix the deal by
working to make it better but TPP was a
trade partnership with a bunch of
countries that did not include China it
was directed against China and by proxy
against North Korea because obviously
North Korea is just
Rocsi state for the chinese the chinese
have been gaining in power in the region
for the last two decades thanks to
american benevolence in the region and
the fact that President Trump pulled out
of the TPP through a lot of countries
into the arms of China or at least under
the outstretched missile umbrella of the
Chinese none of that is particularly
good and so in President Trump talks
about removing troops from the South
Korean Peninsula and allowing the North
Koreans to have essentially military
parity with South Koreans on the
peninsula I'm not saying they're gonna
go to war I am saying that the North
Koreans and the Chinese then have the
ability to pressure South Korea in a way
they otherwise would not and there are a
lot of South Koreans who are not
particularly happy with the Americans as
it is so none of this is particularly
good policy if the president really
wants to force North Korea's hands he's
going to need to do what he likes to do
which is be more muscular or not less
muscular and meeting with with kim
jeong-hoon under these circumstances
without any clear agenda there's talk
that president Trump wants to have a
follow-up meeting in Mara wah and Kim
Jong loon is gonna come in and play golf
with him presumably so presumably the
the final score for each of them will be
18 because Kim jong-un famous for having
scored 18 holes in one one of the things
about the cult of personality in North
Korea that's somewhat amusing if you can
call them using a giant dictatorship is
the fact that they put out all these
press releases about how Kim Jong hoon
is the best golfer who ever lived
they've literally put out the seriously
they put out actual press releases
saying that Kim Jong hoon has golf like
18 on a full golf course that he's had
18 holes in one because of this cult of
personality President Trump is known to
to inflate his his own golf prowess on a
fairly regular basis so if they go
golfing together at the very least we'll
get some amusing headlines out of it but
I'm not sure again that we should be
spending our time and effort really
attempting to reach out to a regime
without any clear plan for what goes
forward again I'm happy to be proved
wrong here but I'm gonna have to be
proved wrong because I just don't think
the meetings for the sake of meetings
are good and until five minutes ago
neither did most conservatives now
speaking of meetings that seems to have
gone wildly wrong president Trump went
up to the g7 in Canada and things did
not go well so the g7 is a trade group
it's they're supposed to get together
where they discuss all sorts of
important international issues and this
group does not include Russia so the
president last week said that he wanted
the group to include Russia that he
would prefer that the group include
Russia Russia has been
out of the g7 ever since they invaded
Ukraine President Trump for no apparent
reason wants Russia back in hey that's
foolish and then he goes up to the g7 he
did a couple things that are good and he
did a couple things that are bad I mean
this is just a beautiful example of good
Trump bad from so a couple of things
that he did that we're good is the
president refused to get together for
the equal female equality summit right
where we all get together and we pretend
that in the West
there's all sorts of institutional
barriers to women succeeding that is not
true in the United States it's certainly
not true in Europe either but all of
these leaders like to get together and
mouth off about it because all these
European leaders aren't have left that
was the good okay the bad was that the
president went there and decided that he
was going to start a trade war so the
president has a very peculiar notion on
trade his peculiar notion on trade is
that America is better off if it doesn't
do it then America is stronger if we
trade less with other countries and when
we we have to be clear when we say
America should trade less with other
countries we don't mean the American
government should trade less with other
countries we mean that the American
people should trade less with other
countries so you should not buy a
product that was made in Korea or China
or Indonesia or England or France or
Germany hidden by a German luxury
vehicle you should buy American dammit
and this somehow is gonna make America
stronger now the problem with that of
course is that means that you're
spending more money for an inferior
product in many cases many of these
foreign companies have bases in the
United States where they manufacture
parts that go into their own cars
Mercedes has factories in the United
States Toyota has massive factories down
in the southern United States and when
you boycott Toyota you're not
necessarily helping Americans in fact
what you're doing is shifting your own
money from the pockets of Americans who
are in more efficient industries and
more efficient businesses to the pockets
of Americans in subsidized industries
effectively it's a backhanded tax you
are being taxed to benefit particularly
in distri well president Trump thinks
that that makes a country stronger and
so he likes to look at the so-called
trade deficit the trade deficit is where
Americans spend more on products from
China than Chinese folks spend on
products from America now people who
have paid attention to the trade deficit
it's a complete waste of time it's
really stupid paying attention to the
trade deficit makes no sense because
again you have a trade deficit with
every business you do business with who
does not buy from you you have a trade
deficit with your gas station you have a
trade deficit with your Starbucks you
have a trade deficit with your local
grocery store you have a trade deficit
with every business that you buy from
but does not buy from you you have a
trade deficit with does that mean you
should stop shopping there and instead
of going and getting a cup of coffee at
Starbucks or coffee bean instead you
decide to grow your own coffee trees in
the backyard and hand grind your coffee
is that efficient of course that's not
efficient the whole reason that trade is
efficient is because of comparative
advantage
Starbucks is better and cheaper at
making coffee than you are and you can
take that extra time where you didn't
grow the coffee beans and then grind
them up and make a crappy brew and
instead you can get the somewhat less
crappy brew from Starbucks it can make
all that happen for a couple of bucks
there's a reason that we trade with each
other there is a reason why capitalism
and free markets have raised half the
globe from abject poverty subsistence
economies are giant fails but the
premise of president Trump's view on
trade is that every time you trade with
somebody it's a zero-sum game there's a
winner and there is a loser that is not
true but that is how the president feels
and so he's constantly talking about the
trade deficit well what's happened
inside the Trump administration is this
weird sort of gap where Trump says I
love tariffs they're great right he says
things like tennis make us stronger and
then you got Larry Kudlow who's a free
trader and somebody who actually
understands basic economics 101 who says
you know mr. president trade is actually
quite good if you cut down on trade the
people that hurts most our people in the
Rust Belt who actually need to export
product in order to make a living and
maybe if you like tariffs what you
should do is you should use it as a
retaliatory measure so use it as a way
to ratchet down tariffs from other
countries so president Trump tends to
give to to sort of conflicting messages
with regard to trade and they really do
conflict one is tariffs are great and
the other is tariffs are bad and I'm
gonna use tariffs to fight those tariffs
okay the problem is those mixed messages
end up leading to trade wars because if
the president actually wanted to
negotiation a lowering of he wanted to
negotiate a lowering of trade barriers a
lowering of tariffs he obviously could
do that but he'd actually have to spend
some time negotiating that he couldn't
just start raising trade barriers and
then suggesting the trade barriers
themselves are wonderful it's in just a
second I want to talk about what
President Trump had to say at the g7 and
why it ended up undercutting a lot of
his agenda why it was actually kind of
foolish first I want to say thanks to
our sponsors over at Express GPM so look
at all of these social media monsters do
you really think they're not grabbing
your data they're not using your data
selling your data well you're wrong they
are internet providers like Verizon Time
Warner they can record a list of every
website you visit and they can legally
give it to anyone the Internet is great
it's free it's also the Wild West in
some ways
you're never gonna read those giant
service contracts that say they can
market your information this is why you
need expressvpn expressvpn allows you to
privately and securely surf the internet
without being tracked by anyone and you
can set it up on all your devices it
only takes a few minutes and set it up
on your phone you can set it up on your
laptop it runs in the background it runs
seamlessly on my desktop laptop
smartphone tablet it protects me well
I'm browsing streaming downloading files
or emailing you don't want if this is
especially great if you tend to use
public Wi-Fi where somebody could steal
your passwords expressvpn prevents all
of that so you can safely surf public
Wi-Fi spots hotspots in that Starbucks
or the hotels or the airports without
having to worry about somebody snooping
on your personal information and for
less than seven bucks a month you can
get the same expressvpn protection that
I have every expressvpn plan is covered
by a risk free 30-day money-back
guarantee so try it see if you like it
see if it works for you and then if you
don't you can always get your money back
so check it out take your internet
privacy back today and find out how you
can get three months for free so go to
expressvpn comm slash Ben that's Express
VPN expr ESS VPN comm slash ban for
three months for free don't put it off
because you never know who's stealing
your information today expressvpn comm
slash been for three months free don't
put it off protect your internet and
data with expressvpn today okay so
president trump as I say has been
issuing conflicting messages about trade
and at the g7 he did this on a routine
basis so he starts off this press
conference he hails heard of this
impromptu press conference at which he
talked about trade and how the g7 was
going and he says there's no reason that
we should have had a trade deficit in
the first place it's ridiculous it's
unacceptable here's what he has to say
there was no reason that this should
have happened last year they lost 800 we
as a nation over the years but the
latest numbers 817 billion dollars one
trade that's ridiculous and it's
unacceptable first of all that's
ridiculous and unacceptable it's not
it's not true we did not lose 817
billion dollars on trade when I give my
money to a Chinese company that Chinese
company cannot spend those dollars in
China it has to then spend those dollars
on American products or services or
investments the Chinese have largely
been using that money to buy American
bonds and fund the national debt then
nobody in the government seems to give
any craps about so that's just not true
Trump continues along these lines but
now
here's the conflicting message rights on
the one hand he says we have these trade
deficits that are really bad if you
think trade deficits are bad the
solution is tariffs then he says but I
hate terrorists tariffs are terrible so
you've got Trump at war with Trump now
so here's Trump talking about how he
wishes to get rid of all the tariffs no
tariffs no barriers that would that's
the way it should be
and no subsidies I even said no tariffs
in other words let's say Canada where we
have tremendous tariffs the United
States pays tremendous tariffs on dairy
as an example two hundred and seventy
percent nobody knows that we pay nothing
we don't want to pay anything so which
is it you want tariffs higher or lower
our tariffs good in and of themselves or
are they bad in of themselves again
Trump back and forth so here's Trump
saying that he doesn't like trade
deficits and we can't lose he says we
increased tariffs we can't lose well no
that's not the point
right the idea here is that if you're
increasing tariffs you are losing but
you're attempting to leverage the other
side into stopping stopping their own
tariffs but Trump seems to be a little
confused on policy and as an example
with one country we have 375 billion in
trade deficits we can't lose you could
make the case that they lost years ago
but when you're down 375 billion you
can't lose and we have to bring them up
so there's very bad spirit when we have
a big trade imbalance and we want to
bring it up to balance just balance and
they keep raising it so that you never
catch that's not a good thing to do and
we have very very strong measures that
take care of that because we do so much
the the numbers are so astronomically
against them in terms of anything as per
your question we win that war a thousand
times out of it right so on the one hand
he keeps saying I want zero tariffs I
want no barriers and on the other hand
he says we can go to when we can win and
trade wars are very easy right they're
very easy and then he says that we're
actually in the strength in America
through tariffs so which is it our
tariffs just a measure that we're using
to ratchet down other nations tariffs
that makes certain mountain
okay with that or our turfs actually
inactive good our tariffs going to make
our country stronger
okay so Trump obviously likes tariffs
okay here's the reality he's had this
perspective on trade since the 1980s he
believes that America is being screwed
by trade or whatever it's not
economically literate but that's the way
that he feels about all of this now none
of this would have made a huge
difference if the President had just
gone and signed this ga seven statements
there's this big statement you're
supposed to sign at the very end in
which they talk about why free trade is
great and Trump refused to sign it
because he got miffed and why'd he get
miffed he got miffed because as I said
with regard to kim jeong-hoon the
personal relationships went south so at
the beginning of this press conference
where he's talking about how this
meeting went he says that the
relationship he has with all of these
world leaders is just great well this is
not true okay most of these world
leaders can't stand him and he can't
stand them President Trump does not get
along with these world leaders which in
many cases is fine I don't think that's
particularly important but to Trump it's
important so here was Trump talking
about the relationships that he has with
all of these people the leaders of these
countries this is a clip 9 the
relationship that I've had with the
people the leaders of these countries
has been I would really rate it on a
scale of 0 to 10 I would rate it at 10
that doesn't mean I agree with what
they're doing and they know very well
that I don't
so we're negotiating very hard tariffs
and barriers a lot of these countries
actually smile at me when I'm talking
and the smile is we couldn't believe we
got away with it that's a smile so it's
gonna change it's gonna change they have
no choice it's not gonna change we're
not gonna trade with them we're not
gonna okay so I love this he doesn't
actually have an actual goal here right
his goal supposedly is to lower their
tariffs but if they don't lower their
tariffs he's gonna raise tariffs and
then even if they do lower their tariffs
he's still kind of likes tariffs he says
it doesn't change like does anyone
really believe by the way that all of
these countries sit down across from the
presidents of the United States and he
says because you're screwing us on trade
and they start smiling them knowingly
like yeah we know we're screwing you on
trade dude what is it they're smiling
because he doesn't know what he's
talking about on trade now again as I
say you can use tariffs as a way to
ratchet down other tariffs this is Larry
Kudlow spoilery Kudlow is the
president's chief economic adviser and
here is what Kudlow had to say on
Trump's plan standing next to trump
right Princeton
would reduce his barriers in fact go to
zero zero tariffs zero non-tariff
barriers zero subsidies and along the
way we're gonna have to clean up the
international trading system about which
there was virtual consensus of agreement
on that and that will be a target and
these are the best ways to promote
economic growth will all be better it
will be strong right okay so Kudlow is
speaking of Trump the first right this
is the perspective that you use tariffs
in order to ratchet down other tariffs
Trump is speaking Trump the second which
is his real perspective which is let's
raise tariffs on everybody at every time
he's already talking about raising
tariffs on cars
he's already raised it on steel and
aluminum okay so all of this would have
been okay except that the other
countries decided to kick back and Trump
does not take kindly to other countries
kicking back which created for him some
pretty good images actually so a lot of
people on the left in the United States
say oh it's from humiliated himself at
the g7 it's really going to hurt him at
the g7 I'll explain why it's not going
to hurt him at the g7 in just a second
first you're gonna have to go over to
Daily wire so for $9.99 a month you can
get the rest of this show live for the
rest for $9.99 a month and get the rest
of Michael Mobile's execrable show live
and the rest of Andrew clavin's show
live you can also ask us questions and
get us you can ask me questions and get
all of your lives problem solved right
when we do our Father's Day special
tomorrow you can ask well I have
questions and you can have all those
questions answered or not answer it if
you're asking Michael anything because
he's not capable of answering things you
can do all those things when you
subscribe and for $99 a year you get all
of that Plus this the greatest and
beverage vessels the leftist here's hot
or cold tumblr behold gaze upon this and
wonder look look okay it's amazing okay
also you probably heard by now the Ben
Shapiro show is available on Amazon
website in Google home so if you've a
virtual assistant you can listen to my
podcast with a simple voice command
after you enable the skill on alexa or
ask google to talk to the show for more
information check out our pins which on
facebook and twitter also please
subscribe at youtube and soundcloud in
itunes because if you do then you know
you already got the sunday special this
week and it was a great sunday special
we had jonah goldberg
i blues it who's next sunday special
it's michael shermer so michael shermer
is stopping by for our next Sunday's
special which is gonna be awesome
michael shermer of course is the the
editor of skeptic magazine we talk about
religion and god and all sorts of
wonderful stuff so you're going to want
to check that out please subscribe
please leave us a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so as I say president Trump is all over
the place on trade right sometimes he is
very Pro trade right zero tariffs zero
barriers and other times he says tariffs
are wonderful in and of themselves but
they're all great but none of this
really would have mattered in terms of
the outcome from the g7 everybody sort
of would have futs their way through it
except that the other countries were not
willing to sit by and let trump do this
routine so Guerra isn't not so Justin
Trudeau who's handsome Bernie Sanders he
is still more Pro free trade than
president Trump there there's talk
yesterday about his eyebrow coming down
his face that his eye bruh actually came
loose that is not true okay his eyebrow
is not actually loose you can if you can
see this visually then you see that his
left eyebrow appears to be sliding down
his face of those he's wearing weird
fake eyebrows that are sliding down his
face especially his natural eyebrow
oddly enough in any case that is beside
the point
Justin Trudeau ripped into president
Trump on tariffs and he said listen
we're not gonna do this trade war thing
if he wants to do this then I guess that
we're going to have to retaliate and in
Canada's already announced retaliatory
measures on some of trumps tariffs it
would be with regret but it would be
with absolute certainty and firmness
that we move forward with retaliatory
measures on July first applying
equivalent tariffs to the ones that the
Americans have unjustly applied to us I
have made it very clear to the president
that it is not something we relish doing
but it is something that we absolutely
will do because Canadians were polite
were reasonable but we also will not be
pushed around okay so this set Trump off
right this set Trump off the trunk got
very angry because Justin Trudeau said
that Trump had basically started this
trade war which is kind of true I mean
we didn't have a trade war until five
minutes ago and then Trump decided that
he was gonna raise tariffs supposedly
because he wanted to lower tariffs in
Canada but really cuz he kind of likes
tariffs and and this caused president
Trump to start tweeting right the tweet
storm began category five hurricane
tweet storm he said the United States
would not allow other countries to
impose massive tariffs and trade
barriers and it's farmers workers and
companies without sending their product
into our country tax-free we have put up
with trade abuse for many decades and
that is long enough okay the truth is
trade barriers have been lowered over
the course of many decades to the point
where the average trade barrier
Canada to the US they're products like
1.6% ok these are not massive trade
barriers in most cases and the ones that
are they're bad
raising our own tariffs in other areas
in retaliation would be one thing but
doing it because you can't really sort
of like the tariffs is another here's
President Trump continuing and again the
conflicting message based on Justin's
false statements at his news conference
and the fact that Canada is charging
massive terrorists to our US farmers
workers and companies I have instructed
our US reps not to endorse the
communique as we look at tariffs and
automobiles flooding newest markets and
now he's talking about massive tariffs
on automobiles coming into American
markets how is that beneficial to the
American consumer he can't explain it's
not gonna be good for the economy the
White House's own report suggests this
won't be good for the economy if you
were arguing again that you're raising
the tariffs in order to knock candidates
that they knock down their own tariffs
that's one thing but that's not where
Trump goes next
my Trump continues along these lines and
then he suggests Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau of Canada acted so meek and mild
during our g7 conference only to give a
news conference after I left saying u.s.
tariffs were kind of insulting and he
will not be pushed around very dishonest
and weak our tariffs are in response to
his of 270 percent under a okay so he
picks out one tariff and then he says
we're gonna raise tariffs I'm like
everything and then he says it's Justin
Trudeau's fault for kicking back and all
of this stuff see this is why you should
have a negotiation not a Twitter fight
or go in there with an actual agenda
which President Trump obviously did not
do and again like I am NOT Justin
Trudeau fan I'm not Justin Trudeau as
hard as anybody on the air finally the
president continues again there's a
massive tweed storm so President Trump
this morning was continuing with all of
this he just he was in Singapore and he
still wouldn't stop it so he if he was
continuing along these lines in
Singapore this morning and here is what
he tweeted he tweeted fair trade is now
to be called fool a trade if it is not
reciprocal according to a Canada release
they make almost a hundred billion
dollars in trade with us guess they were
bragging and got caught
minimum is 17 billion tax dairy from us
at 270 percent then Justin acts hurt
when called out they don't make a
hundred billion dollars in trade with us
if we have a trade deficit with Canada
he says why should I as president of the
United States allow countries to
continue to make massive trade surpluses
as they have for decades not fair to the
people of America again this is wrong
this is not wrong and then he says the
EU as one
51 billion-dollar trade surplus with the
United States and they should pay more
for their military this evidence is lack
of knowledge about trade and it once
again evidence is that the real reason
the Trump is mad here is because people
said that they didn't have great
relationships right now this led to some
really untoward language by members of
the Trump administration so here is
Larry Kudlow saying that Justin Trudeau
stabbed we're going to war with Canada
guys that's it I mean I'm excited about
this I I want a piece of Quebec so Larry
Kudlow says that Justin Trudeau stabbed
us in the back until five minutes ago
the Canadians were our friends now I
guess we're gonna have to go to war with
her northern with our northern neighbors
I mean this has now turned into an
episode of South Park with President
Trump shouting blame Canada here is
Larry Kudlow saying that Justin Trudeau
stabbed us in the back here's the thing
I mean he really kind of stabbed us in
the back
he really actually you know what he did
a great disservice to the whole g7 he'd
betray her no dude yes he did because
they were united in the g7 they came
together okay so they came together but
then Trudeau ripped it all apart not the
president Yeah right okay here's Peter
Navarro who went even farther Peter
Navarro is isn't it yet I mean I'm just
gonna put that out there Peter of are
was a dummy and Peter Navarro is one of
the president's trade advisors who
believes that a giant trade war will
lift the United States he actually
believes this and then he said there was
a special place in hell for Trudeau so I
guess there's a special place in hell
for women who don't defend other women
according to Madeleine Albright there's
now a special place in hell for leaders
like Justin Trudeau which is really
exciting we're running out of like
regular hell what happened to regular
hell I guess it's now been subdivided up
into special places there's so many
special places in hell it's like the
Epcot Center in hell there's just a
bunch of weird little food stands and
they sell crappy garbage apparently to
Justin Trudeau
and women who won't offend other women
here's Peter Navarro saying that Justin
Trudeau has now a special place in Hell
where everyone I guess says eh I guess
that's just called Canada here he is
Chris there's a special place in the
hell for any foreign leader that engages
in bad faith diplomacy with President
Donald J Trump and then tries to stab
him in the back on the way out the door
and that's what bad faith Justin Trudeau
did with that stunt press conference
that's what weak dishonest Justin
Trudeau did okay so look the reality is
a lot of the people on TV are performing
for president Trump demonstrating that
they they agree with President Trump
that's how you stay in good with
President Trump it's one of the problems
I have with his style of governance
which is that the president likes to
feel like a strong man and so he likes
when people around him say yes to him
and say yes mr. president that's what
you did was so genius mr. president if
Larry Kudlow wants to impact free trade
he has to go on TV and pretend that
Trump is actually a free trader but if
anybody believes it's gonna hurt Trump
they are wrong okay they're totally
wrong if they believe that is gonna hurt
Trump in any serious way I'll explain
why in just a second so from the g7
there was this from the g7 there was a
picture that came out and here was the
picture hey this is passed around in in
a lot of media circles this was taken
about the German delegation and if you
can't see it what the picture shows is
Angela Merkel who is standing over a
table by gazing down glaring at
president Trump and president Trump has
on his Fu smile right he's got his arms
crossed he's looking back up there like
what's she gonna do lady and they are
surrounded by a bunch of other foreign
leaders he can see Shinzo Abe a who's
from Japan he's kind of apparently
thinking about why West world sucks now
he's kind of gazing off into the
distance not understanding what's going
on john bolton is like a like what's
going but Angela Merkel is staring down
angrily at President Trump and a lot of
people I'm left like this is what
America has become if you think that
hurts president Trump domestically in
any way you out of your mind you're
crazy if you believe that hurts Trump
Trump standing up to foreign leaders is
why President Trump was elected Trump
standing up to foreign leaders and not
backing down is is why people like
President Trump in the first place so is
this gonna hurt President Trump no is
any of this gonna matter in the end only
if President Trump decides to pursue
these tariffs see if he decides to
pursue the tariffs he's going to put a
damper on the economy that has been
booming under his watch there's no
reason for him to do this he will be
blamed if the economy goes south and if
the tariffs go into place in the economy
goes south
he should be blamed I mean that he
should have a part of that blame okay
now meanwhile I have to bring you this
story from the Washington Post because
it's just insane there's an opinion
column by susana - nuta walters a
professor of uselessness sociology and
director of the women's gender and
sexuality studies program in
Northeastern University where they study
a bunch of crap that they pay her for
and she wrote a piece this is for the
Washington Post it is literally called
why can't we hate men
why can't we hate men that's the name of
the piece now suffice it to say and if
you name
that piece why can't we hate the blacks
people might be like um that's horrible
or we say why can't we hate women that
might be sexist say why we can't why
can't we hate the udin that might be
Nazi but why can't we hate men from
feminists totally fine now you might
think that that's just an over-the-top
title for clickbait nope that's the
entire piece it says it's not that Eric
Schneiderman the now former New York
Attorney General accused of abuse by
multiple women pushed me over the edge
my edge has been crossed for a long time
before President Trump before Harvey
Weinstein before man's planning in in
cells before live-streaming sexual
assaults and red pill men's groups and
rape camps as a tool of war and the
deadening banality of male prerogative
seen in this innit indisputably true
context it seems logical to hate men
really does it because I have not been a
part of a rape camp red pill men's
groups I don't know who she's talking
about i if that's people who believe
that women are not generally being
discriminated against an American side I
guess that's maybe I don't know why that
sexist mansplaining in in cells like
what just I can't lie I've always had a
soft spot for the radical feminist smack
down no shocker can't believe it says
for naming the problem in no uncertain
terms
I've rankled at that but we don't hate
men prata stations and generations would
be feminists and found the men are not
the problem the system is obfuscate too
precious by half but of course the
criticisms of this blanket condemnation
of men from transnational feminists who
decry such glib universalism to us women
of color who demands an intersectional
perspective are mostly on the mark these
critics rightly insist on an analysis of
male power as institutional not narrowly
personal or individual or biologically
based in male bodies growing movement to
challenge masculinity built on
domination and violence and to engage
boys and men and feminism both
gratifying and necessary please continue
so a bunch of gobbledygook plus teach
boys to be feminist but this recognition
of the complexity of male domination
should not must not mean we forget some
universal facts pretty much everywhere
in the world this is true women
experience sexual violence and the
threat of that violence permeates our
choices big and small women in America
do not experience pervasive sexual
violence they do not okay there there is
sexual violence in the United States but
the notion that women across the United
States are victimized by sexual violence
is just bullcrap
okay the statistics do not bear this out
women are raped it's awful the men
should be castrated or killed to believe
that women across the United States are
experiencing this stuff is just not true
and if you're going to boil down sexual
violence to a cat call or a whistle then
you are
idiot Hey look at actual sexual violence
all those things are wrong can catcalls
whistles these are not good things but
to proclaim that this is sexual violence
that means that all men are evil is
idiotic an additional in addition she
says male violence is not restricted to
intimate partner attacks or sexual
assault but plagues us in the form of
terrorism nests gun violence so
apparently when there's a mass shooting
it's women who are being targeted which
we have no evidence for and then she
finally concludes it is long past time
to play hard for Team feminism and win
step away from power men we got this and
please know that your crocodile tears
won't be wiped away by us anymore we
have every right to hate you you have
done us wrong well I have every right
then to hate intersectional feminist
like this who are vile and make the
society worse amazing the Washington
Post would put would print this garbage
but not all that amazing since they are
indeed the Washington Post okay time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like this
is really a thing that I hate but the
announcement is a thing that is amazing
so charles krauthammer i is the dean of
conservative columnist he's sort of the
heir to William F Buckley he was his
generations William F Buckley a
columnist for The Washington Post a
Pulitzer Prize winner and he has now put
out a statement he is he'll knee is
expected to live for a few weeks and he
put out a beautiful statement at the end
of last week he concludes his statement
this way he says I thank my colleagues
my readers and my viewers who have made
my career possible and given consequence
to my life's work I believe that the
pursuit of truth and right ideas through
honest debate and rigorous argument is a
noble undertaking I'm grateful to have
played a small role in the conversations
that have helped guide this
extraordinary nation's destiny I leave
this life with no regrets it was a
wonderful life full and complete with
the great loves and great endeavors that
make it worth living I am sad to leave
but I leave with the knowledge that I
lived the life that I intended yeah
would that everybody yeah and not only
has this grace but lives the life that
they intended would that everybody dies
with that sort of feeling of
accomplishment as Charles Krauthammer as
well he should've been Charles
Krauthammer is amazing guys from Charles
Krauthammer when he was in Harvard
Medical School he was in a diving
accident and he was paralyzed from the
neck down and he went on to get his
psychiatric degree from Harvard Medical
School he worked on the DSM 2 and then
he became a columnist on politics and
culture and won the Pulitzer Prize and
of course he saw him every night on Fox
News so he will be passing away in the
next few weeks according to his doctors
a tremendous loss for not only the
conservative movement
for the cause of gentility and decency a
really decent human being I met Charles
Krauthammer twice once was in his office
where he already asked probing questions
between talk about baseball and once was
actually over the Praeger new offices
where he was cutting a video for them
and I was over in the offices at the
time we had a little bit of time to chat
just an amazing person depth of mind
depth of curiosity and and a truly
profound soul so the world it will be
lesser for his loss thank God for that
we all had the experience of getting to
watch Charles Krauthammer at work a
wordsmith and a deep thinker at the same
time which is an amazing thing okay time
for some things that I hate so speaking
of people who are not wordsmiths or deep
thinkers let's talk about the Tony
Awards last night so the Tony Awards
happened last night and apparently the
deep thinkers at the Tony Awards felt
the necessity to virtue signal to all of
their friends in the in the theater
industry this began with Robert DeNiro
Sir Robert DeNiro gets up and he gives a
very eloquent statement of why he
opposes president Trump like a very
eloquent deep statement of why President
Trump ought to be ousted and is a grave
threat to the system of American
democracy
[Applause]
Trump okay we briefed it out he says eff
Trump right there standing ovation
standing ovation I'm just gonna say one
thing up Trump such bravery stunning
bravery no longer down with Trump it's F
Trump o bravery bravery beyond all
measure bravery beyond all capacity I'm
sure that everyone in that audience
hated Trump until that moment and then
Robert DeNiro spoke truth to power and
suddenly all of the love that they had
had for Trump up till then and turned to
hate wow what what unbelievable Bret
just speaking truth and the explanation
I mean the real fulsome explanation of
why he opposes president Trump there
really is quite meaningful I will say
like I thought it was a convincing case
a beautifully convincing case by Robert
DeNiro for why you shouldn't support
President Trump and good for Amit what
an amazing dude Robert DeNiro is and
then Andrew Garfield gets up so Andrew
Garfield who recall from such great
movies as spider-man the reboot that was
then rebooted Andrew Garfield is in
Angels in America so Angels in America
remember as a tendentious over long
ridiculous crappy TV series from HBO
starring half of Hollywood is like a
nine hour meditation on homosexuality in
America from like 1960s on and they made
a seven-hour vodka Aryan production of
it for Broadway in which Andrew Garfield
plays a young gay man suffering from
AIDS and enter Garfield gets up at the
Tony Awards where a quarter of the
audience probably is gay and he starts
lecturing Americans in front of the
cameras about the masterpiece cake shop
case because he doesn't know anything
about law or about apparently decency so
he gets up and then he starts talking
about let's let's let's down with the
Supreme Court so we had Robert DeNiro F
Trump and now we have Andrew Garfield
speaking from the heart about why
Christians should be forced to violate
their own religious precepts we are all
sacred and we all belong so let's just
bake a cake for everyone who wants a
cake to be baked so let's just baked a
cake fine I ask you Andrew Garfield I'm
gonna write a play about masterpiece
cake shop it's about how the Christian
family in that case was victimized by
vindictive LGBT activists and who almost
ruined their business and destroyed
their lives I would like you to play the
lead I would like Andrew Garfield to
play the lead as the Christian man who
refused service to the same-sex wedding
out of religious conviction and that
almost had his life destroyed by a bunch
of vindictive bureaucrats and you should
play that lead act the part you know if
everybody why can't we all just act the
parts that we're asked to act I'm happy
to pay your salary I'll raise the money
to do it and you can star it in Andrew
Garfield I mean I'm serious about this I
will go raise the money right now if you
pledges to act in this play I will write
it and then we'll go get the money and
Andrew Garfield can act it'll be great
because he shouldn't have any say as to
what sort of parts he acts he should
just act whatever part comes in front of
him and if he has moral scruples about
that part well why can't he be tolerance
why can't he be a more tolerant person
why can't he just act the part that
people want him to act and are willing
to pay him to act I'm willing even pay
him his money I'm not saying do it for
free
hey this is the stupidity of this
position hey this idea just baked the
cake just bake the cake what if I don't
want to make the cake it's a free damn
country I get to not bake the cake if I
don't want to bake the cake and the fact
that Andrew Garfield stands up there and
is lecturing everybody about what cake
to make he's an artist too he should
know he should know when it is
appropriate and when it is not to force
people to do things
he has an artist I do not get to force
my perception of what Andrew Garfield
should act upon Andrew Garfield that's
not the way this works even though he's
in the public square even though he's
operating in the area of Commerce I
don't get to do that but according to
Andrew Garfield everybody else should
have to do that because he is upset that
gay weddings aren't gonna get the cake
from the Christian shop as opposed to
the cake from every other bake shop in
America owned by a gay person like it's
just it's ridiculous and it's
over-the-top and again it's virtually
signaling in front of a bunch of people
who agree with him and so he gets big
cheers for that if you want to actually
be brave you should have gone out there
and said we all need to tolerate one
another and that means that I'm willing
to tolerate the Christian Baker who
doesn't want to cater my same-sex
wedding and the Christian Baker should
tolerate me when I come in and ask for a
cake he doesn't he doesn't wanna do that
right instead he wants to engage in in a
bit of let me tell you what to do which
is what the entire left apparently wants
to do now so that's just that's just
wonderful okay final thing that I hate
so Bill Maher who is good on some issues
and bad on some issues I will give him
credit for honesty here Bill Maher is
not a fan of president Trump's that's
his prerogative but then he just drops
it that he would like to see an economic
downturn taos Trump oh yeah now I'm old
enough to remember when Rush Limbaugh
said in 2009 right after Barack Obama's
election that he hope Obama fails we
meant by that is he hopes that President
Obama failed in his attempts to
implement Obama s policy not that he
wanted to see the economy downturn not
that he wanted to see the the fiscal
state of America collapse or America's
power on his foreign stage collapse he
just didn't want to see Obama's policies
promulgated he wanted him to fail in
pursuing his policies well Bill Maher is
a little more open than that but larger
says I want the economy to fail I want
millions of people thrown out of work so
Trump will be ousted I feel like the
bottom has to fall out at some point and
by the way I'm hoping for it because I
think one way you get rid of Trump is a
crashing economy so please bring on the
recession sorry if that hurts people but
it's either roofer recession or you lose
your democracy
okay so roofer recession or you lose
your democracy or maybe you just make
the case against Trump in terms that are
rational and then we can all decide
whether that's convincing or not but you
know when you're when you're now rooting
for millions of people to be thrown out
of work because you want to see you to
have a bad impact on the on the
president of the United States I said
it's probably not a good thing okay
we'll be back here tomorrow with all the
latest i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018